should new TV writers focus on pitching
their shows to Studios and networks
so what's happening now I would say the
trend in this business is if you are a
writer who's actively Staffing
there there is a limit to your ability
to pitch most Studios contractually will
not allow you to start pitching projects
until you reach like co-producer level
so unless you already had something that
another Studio was interested in and you
can do what's called a carve out where
it's protected from your contract you
really are not developing if you're
Staffing constantly if you staffed once
and then you're having trouble finding
another job your reps are going to be
like well what do you have that we can
take out and pitch because it's a way to
keep you in the game
it's a way to get you out there meeting
people and sometimes it happens
sometimes newer writers sell shows and
they get made and that's amazing the
biggest obstacle when you are a newer
lower level writer and you sell a show
is that you do not have the skill set to
be a sure Runner
so what will generally happen unless you
are some wonderkind that they're gonna
they're gonna just decide you have all
it takes to be a showrunner is that an
experienced showrunner is going to be
attached to your show
and hopefully you will have some input
and how that choice is made hopefully
you can bring some names to the table if
there's you know producers you really
admire executive producers and show
Runners that you really like or who's
who you a friend of a friend told you
this person's like the greatest human
being and they might be available to run
it bring their name in a lot of times
the studios or the networks will already
have a list of people they want you to
consider you should be able to talk to
those people and give your input on who
you think is best and like this is the
person I think should run it with me
usually it's fine
um because you know most of the people
who get brought in to run a show for a
different Creator are on overall deals
and they're looking to help you get your
show off the ground so they can go make
their stuff they're really not invested
in taking your show over
there are however times that that
happens to pre to people and and this
town is full of those stories of you
know brilliant writer made the show and
then big dog producer basically pushed
them out the door and it happens and I
think you shouldn't let fear of that
stop you if someone's interested in
making your show and you're an
inexperienced writer you just need to
educate yourself on how to best protect
yourself
and don't try to protect yourself by
being like it's my show like you can't
tell me anything about it you have to
build that partnership because TV is a
team sport and anyone who's not
supporting the team is a problem
so you don't want to be a problem and
then lose any say in what happens to
your show that you created so it's a
tricky thing but it does happen and you
know reps will encourage Young Riders to
be writing pilots and trying to you know
get interest and even have them out
pitching but it's always with the
understanding that you will probably not
be running that show
and is that the scenario where someone
would say I I don't take notes is if
it's actually their their idea they're
the ones that came up with the show idea
the I don't take notes people are
um you know just certain showrunners of
a certain personality there was a pretty
widely publicized article where like
Taylor Sheridan says he doesn't take
notes
okay like I guess he doesn't you know
um there have been some other writers
that have sort of expressed that again I
think that's a if that's your
personality and that's how you move
through the world
then I understand that that's you're not
going to be different right in this
process you're going to try and do
exactly the thing you always do which is
like I know best so I'm going to do it
my way
I think most writers are not that person
most writers are
understand that someone else might have
an idea that's additive to what they've
written and it's very rarely even
scripts that I think are brilliant very
rarely that I'm not like oh this could
be better though like sometimes there's
just little things that sometimes you're
so close to it you can't see it and so
having other writers around you or
having a good executive say hey this
script is brilliant the one thing I
would say to you is these transitions
are a little confusing and a director is
not going to understand how you want it
done and you know the audience may not
track it so let's think about how to
rethink that that's a good note like you
need to look at that because they're
concerned about your show succeeding as
opposed to
I just don't understand magic why is
there magic in this show that's not
helpful if they've bought a magic show
but sometimes it happens
should there be a time limit let's say
for a newer writer should expect
to work five to ten years in a writer's
room before they actually think they can
go and Pitch their own show
or that's just there's no real hard and
fast rule there's no real hard and fast
rule there used to be definitely
um you know I interviewed with some
showrunners who had come up in the era
before I really came in to the business
and it really used to be very like you
just don't run a show till you become a
co-ep on other people's shows
um and coep being the top level of
writer before you're an executive
producer
nowadays it's it's much more
free-flowing it's you know I know people
who have been
soldiers as staff writers who have sold
shows as you know uh producers which is
pretty right solid in the middle and
then also as coeps so it's kind of all
over the place now I think
what I would say is
really think about if if all you're
focused on is that you want to sell your
own show
staff as much as you can and just know
what you need to learn which is you need
to go to set and produce an episode
that's probably going to happen working
in broadcast television
more than it's ever going to happen in a
streaming situation so take a broadcast
job
and you need to know how post works and
you need to read as much as you can to
help educate you about how this all
works I um you know Carol kirschner has
a great book that's called Hollywood
game plan that really sort of talks
about the the business side of the
business
um Bethany Rooney wrote this amazing
book on directing for television that I
recommend to writers because it talks
about what everyone on set does
so you can really take in what all the
jobs are and because you get all these
words thrown at you like you know
someone's like a grip and someone said
this and someone's of that and you're
like what does all that mean I don't
know like because a lot of us didn't go
to film school so we don't know so you
get the book and you read what people do
and that'll help prepare you because
what you don't want to do is just assume
you know because you're a brilliant
writer how to do it all and then
suddenly you're a showrunner even today
actually John Wells just launched this
thing
um on his website where it's like the
showrunner's corner where he's giving
out advice to people about how to do the
job because we have seen thanks to
streaming this Gap open up in skill sets
for writers because those of us who have
worked in broadcast television have
produced episodes have gone to post have
that experience but people who've like
their whole career's been on streaming
shows never been to set never allowed to
see Cuts they haven't been to post and
so there's this Gap in in the skills you
need to run a show happening for a whole
generation of writers and so there's a
lot of concern about how to fix that so
I was so pleased today to see that John
was like well here's a step here's this
foreign